welcome to this video playing Greg
master Yoshi from the United States and
I recently had a game I can't stay which
was quite funny we get to get this again
okay which was funny because I allowed
her easily check made when I was the
queen up and I now totally winning there
should be two were interesting
interesting movie might lead two to the
Scotch game with reversed colors if he
goes we should be be five at some point
that he doesn't um still us this this is
very oh yeah it's very unambitious
opening form for white but okay play a
little of course um yeah I know this is
probably useful Bishop g5 can can happen
at some point why should I play this
maybe maybe I can play a form at some
point E for Queen edge form going for
direct attack on the king that might be
possible um here for example it could be
possible where is he going to h2 with
the line I don't know okay come on let's
um let's not waste any big time here and
Queen edge for next intending to just
sacrifice on on age three
it won't be that easy of course it's not
like i can just take there and win but
it looks it looks interesting okay maybe
just bishop everyone here for white
lending some protection I don't think
you can totally ignore this I mean if it
would be my move I just take that and
probably win yeah okay I needed to do
something like that okay and i don't
have the night in the game which is
really a bit of a shame i have this this
very direct and checkmating idea Queen
FYI just has 23 so does not does not
make much sense and and what about III
though if I III takes Queen g3
I can take with the rook III rook takes
Queen g3 Queen f3 at the end and I don't
really have anything anything brilliant
what is his next smooth though I one can
I can i maybe really just rookie six
looks terribly risky okay come ruki 6g
60s d5 but rook g6 and it looks
dangerous maybe this is totally totally
wacky but our KD 5 this is really silly
rd5 Ruby 60 can take a form which are
really having not ah what does silly
game you can just play the five and it's
over maybe dd5 III though could be could
be possible I have gained yeah maybe I
can do that this would be very lucky to
have I wanted to go d5 Luke g6 but he
can just take afore with the rook and I
have nothing or with the night for that
matter or was doing something entirely
different interesting
ok what is what happens if I'd retreat
the Queen now is this possible
not then you will take okay
i knowi for has it probably had a song
game I've been playing like a like a
[ __ ] relief not really good not at all
yeah I know what so he's got the bloody
rukon be 195 are heavens yeah that's
really really not good
cantik continue wow it's really terrible
okay I need to take what else I oh yes
Bishop f4 even more okay I'm a pawn down
in any case so let's make it they get
this and I don't know why I have played
him a couple of times he sometimes does
strange things so should still fight
maybe I can get some counter play here
f5 now f5 Bishop e7 yeah okay this is no
okay I guess Bishop a six maybe no yeah
okay i'm getting c3 back at least I'm
regaining this Paul time morning
Jesus no I cannot I really cannot
protect this great yeah the whole the
whole game was really bad by me this
somehow fits into the whole thing ah
jeez as I couldn't take how unlucky is
that
ran through key to check
check black bars on what a terrible game
yeah this was really a bunch of bunch of
weird decisions I can clean edge for it
I guess it starts with this I came and I
came well maybe this was still ok but
now I rookie 6 is really completely
idiotic it's very ambitious but no it's
probably just not working this is just
one of the good good good ways to to
play now I just I just said just a
moronic move 4 p-6 sd5 threatening me
for hanging ok yeah Tim I mean I think
you really he didn't really see that
with f5 and stuff that this was still ok
but it was just luck in this position
but sometimes it happens yeah I Roxy
three rookie one is of course just just
losing can you fight here with this move
may be and I'm looking for for some way
to continue here because I was certainly
far worse before it's probably still
very bad well the computer is 0.8 it's
not it was more than two points for
white before now he has those sews
little tricks that keep keep the
position okay
yeah it's um it's still a better
position for what its materially equal
now which is quite funny considering how
bad it was before but so bad yeah this
was just a bad game Wow okay thanks for
watching anyway